the new trailer for the long awaited chainsaw man
anime from Mappa studios has dropped, and it's safe
to say that fans are hyped, myself included,
now iknow what you're all thinking...
"what? anime culturecorner posted tonight? i thought he said he couldn't!"
well, i forgot there was a chainsaw man trailer
coming out last night and, uh, i mean screw it icould not resist.
so i reluctantly set up my new computer
very, very, reluctantly
i woke up thismorning and the trailer it was like an early
christmas present the animation looks incredible
the lack of censorship in the trailer is a
really good sign going forward and it all just
looked really really crisp and oh my god makima
*angelic music*
someone call the cops because bro we got a new
wave of makima stands coming and they're about
to get up to no good, none at all – the show isn't
even animated we got like two seconds of her in
the clip and she's already doing things to me
like oh sheesh if you didn't know already if
you're going to this video without reading
chainsaw man or hearing about it beforehand
chainsaw man is one of the biggest
names out in shonen jump right now
and it certainly set a new precedent for a new
level of maturity and gore in shonen manga it is
part of what we colloquially refer to as the dark
trio in shonen jump, consisting of the recently
finished hell's paradise, the currently on hiatus
series jujitsu kaisen, which i'm sure you all know
and of course chainsaw man which isn't actually
serializing right now as we wait for part two
man i didn't even realize none of them
are coming out with chapters right now
seriously deprived of dark manga at the moment;-;
anyway, having read and enjoyed all three of
these series chainsaw man definitely stands out as
the darkest and probably the most unique
i thinkthe other two, while still generally having more
explicit violence than normal shonen manga, there's
still a lot of shonen tropes and similarities
that chainsaw man really doesn't have it makes
it the dark horse of jump even among these three
and as such it has attracted a huge cult following
chainsaw man is beloved by fans for the depths
to which it goes and complete absence of any
kind of censorship or restrictions as it depicts
some of the most beautiful violence to grace the
pages of mainstream manga – i made a video about it
a while ago back before i even had like a thousand
subscribers which you can check out if you want a
little bit of my insight into the actual manga and
my thoughts on it, but to summarize that like
four-minute something minute video, i love it i love
chainsaw man i was very excited for the anime i
was gushing about it and this trailer has really
gotten my hopes up, but and yes i know there is a
but we do have to be wary of one major thing...
MAPPA
and look, look before you get mad i'm not
the kind of person to hate on mappa at all
i think they do the best with what they're
given and they take on huge titles with an
already massive workload that is totally admirable,
and they do great work but chainsaw man will
either get the jujuto kaisen treatment or the
attack on titan season 4 treatment
keep in mindhow the attack on titan trailer looked compared
to the actual anime there wasn't a single sight
of cg in the trailer but just about every titan
scene in the actual show did have cg in it
again, no cg slander, it was pretty tastefully done
by mappa
not to mention the way characters lookedwas a bit different as well
and again, please,
i want to reiterate that i do not hate attack on
titan season 4 or its animation but there is an
admittable difference between the actual trailer
and the anime i just really hope this
isn't the case with chainsaw man as well
because not only would that be very disappointing
for fans who just saw the trailer, it would
slightly put mapa's reputation down even more, then
it goes from being a one-time small mistake to
a repeated one and precedent that really wouldn't
be very good, but to move past that possible
negative they could also give it the jujutsu
kaisen treatment which would be incredible
the studio isn't burdened this year from what i'm
aware at least not with the year's two biggest
titles like in 2020 so i'm very hopeful that
they can put their everything into chainsaw man
and if you don't understand what the jujustu kaisen
treatment is; it's just insanely good animation
that's that's all it is. it's pretty clear or at
least i hope so that they aren't going to censor
the show based on the trailer which was a lot of
fan's number one worries especially with a series
that relies so heavily on great violent fight
scenes with tons of gore so if if it receives
the jjk treatment and doesn't hold anything back
then it'll definitely hit the ground running
chainsaw man already has such a strong manga fan
base and with the boom that jujutsu kaisen brought
in the anime community i'm confident chainsaw
man's reputation we'll we'll see the same thing
call me a pessimist, but i have a very difficult
time getting my hopes up for anime adaptations
because having high expectations
almost always leads to disappointment
but i really really enjoyed the trailer, the way
the characters had this almost like rough sketch
feel to them they weren't super smooth but almost
had this grainy and rough around the edges feel
to them really fits with the manga–makima looks
hauntingly beautiful as always, and you can really
see the resemblance to jujutsu kaisen animation
in the monsters and character movements here
so if we needed any sign it
was getting that treatment
i mean we've got it, but again trailers can be
misleading–sadly it it wouldn't be the first time
now what do you guys think comment below i mean
the trailer itself stand alone without any worries
was crisp, it was fire, everything from the demons
to the characters to the action if you haven't yet
read the manga i personally recommend doing that
before the anime, not only will it get you more
hype but you'll get a glimpse of one of the best
new dark manga, and you can get ready for part 2 as
well which i'm sure is like light years away from
being animated, plus if the anime does disappoint
then at least you have the comfort of the manga,
but let's all keep our hopes up it looks great
and once again i believe and put my hopes into
mappa best of luck
oh and also if if you're a
real one if you're this far into the video, i've
got a new series planned out that's slated to be
released i don't know within the next couple weeks
about manga that i binge read and my review on
them and rating and all that kind of crap, so if
you're this far if if you're a manga reader or
you want to get into manga look forward to it i'm
really hyped about it and i'll see you guys then
-or actually i'm posting videos before
then, so i guess i'll see you next time
as always this has been the anime culture
corner i hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses :)